nearly 100,000 pro-lifers descend on
Washington DC for this 47th annual March
for life
just one week after fewer than 10,000
shrieking leftists took to the nation's
capital for the fourth annual Women's
March we will examine what the two
back-to-back marches tell us about the
stark difference between the modern left
and the modern right then
Bernie surges to the top of the polls
just days before the Iowa caucuses 7
days out we will analyze how a decrepit
communist became the future of the
Democratic Party
finally some sad news basketball
superstar Kobe Bryant and his young
daughter died in a helicopter crash in
California we will try to make sense of
the tragic news all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
there is a ton to get to right now today
covering the past weekend you know I'm
in Washington DC right now I was here
for the March for Life we put a video up
talked to a lot of people we saw the
president speak the first time the
president ever spoke at the March for
Life and I got to tell you just those
marches the March for Life in the
women's March showed me that the
difference between the left and the
right is getting clearer every day you
know we talked about polarization as a
unqualified evil it's always bad that
the parties are becoming polarized in
some ways it's a good thing because you
can really tell the difference between
the left and the right both parties are
getting more honest they're getting more
clear about what they want about who
they are about what they stand for you
can see it in the presidential race
that's becoming very clear in Iowa and
New Hampshire we'll get to that in a
second because it's pretty shocking news
for the Democratic establishment but
it's it's really clear I think it's most
clear in these two marches the March for
Life and the women's March so I go down
this was truly an historic march for
life there were upwards of a hundred
thousand people there the thing that's
most shocking when you get there is how
young it is you have no idea how young
it is especially because the media don't
cover the event even though it's a
massive annual events been going on
almost 50 years you go there
I think the median age is probably like
19 and these people are so young and I
was trying to understand why is the
March for life so young obviously
they're their parents there and there
are priests and nuns and there are some
politicians and so there are older
people too but mostly it's teenagers and
people in their 20s I think it's because
for young Americans abortion most
visibly affects their generation a full
quarter of Millennials and Gen Z are not
here because of abortion one-fourth of
them have been killed through abortion
so I think it really rings home for them
I spoke to a number of people out there
let's just take a little listen to the
difference between the March for Life in
the women's March here's a young man I
met named Jorge Jorge came up to me at a
sign and said tell us your story
he said hey you still taking stories I
said absolutely he goes alright I've got
one for you
Jorge grew up in foster care here's his
reaction to the pro-abortion movement I
grew up a foster child and I see many
people who use people's bad experiences
in foster care as a supportive reason
for why abortion should be legalized and
even promote abortion for those reasons
because my mother chose life I'm able to
be used as a vessel to help other people
in this world and you don't think that
the suffering that you had to endure it
was just not worth it at all and be
better if you never even had a life know
I'm thankful for the life that I have
and you know if just having that chance
means so much to me and today's a great
day for me to remember that and you're
out here marching and sending a message
to the people who say that people like
you shouldn't even be around no I
actually think that's a very ignorant
argument whether they mean to be
offensive or not to say it's probably
better that you are dead then you have a
hard life that's that's not even their
decision to to be made and it's just a
very ignorant argument you know that's
just one of the stories from March for
life we have a video up at the Daily
wire YouTube page you can check out a
number of them but it's profound because
what Jorge honed in on as he said
suffering is not a reason to end a life
in other words we all suffer life has
suffering and yet life is a beautiful
thing and we'll see that the extreme at
the end of the show and we talk about
Kobe Bryant that's the one side of it
right you talk to people like Jorge you
talk to other people at the March for
life and they are normal for lack of a
better word they are normal they seem
grounded they have a balanced view of
the world they understand that life has
suffering but they're they're happy for
life they're vibrant they're vital you
know the the thing that was so
interesting about speaking to them is
they weren't terribly emotional they had
joy but joy is not just an emotion joy
is this spirit of Hope this this kind of
energy this kind of life and they
weren't terribly emotional they weren't
yelling they weren't screaming they were
just joyful and so President Trump shows
up for the first time ever America
president shows up to the March for Life
he gave a magnificent speech I don't
know who wrote this speech but whoever
did should write more of his speeches
and president Trump delivered it and it
was a really beautiful moment here's
just a little a little sample from
President Trump speech all of us here
today understand an eternal truth every
child is a precious and sacred gift from
God and from the first day in office
I've taken a historic action to support
America's families and to protect the
unborn I notified Congress that I would
veto any legislation that weakens
pro-life policies or that encourages the
destruction of human life unborn
children have never had a stronger
defender in the White House absolutely
right they haven't and I know it's crazy
because what so many people say is
Donald Trump he used to call himself
very pro-choice he's a New York Reese
full of it whatever guys it is simply a
matter of fact that while in office
President Trump has been the most
pro-life president we talked about at
last show more so than Reagan more so
than Bush it was a beautiful moment I
mean I in some way is that when I was
standing there watching the president
from giving this speech I thought this
is the evidence that I'm living in the
simulation then I remembered that the
podcast I'm co-hosting with Ted Cruz has
now become the number one podcast in the
country it actually overtook the Joe
Rogan experience and I thought no I know
I'm living in the simulation we'll get
to that a little bit later
that was the pro-life side of things
okay that was the march for life now
compare that to the women's march that
took place just one week earlier here's
a little taste of the women's March
Donald Trump Mike Pence white supremacy
racism misogyny
homophobia transphobia capitalism
transphobia ableism Islam phobia
anti-semitism so we obviously had to
bleep out exactly half of what she was
saying but I think you can maybe infer
what the word was it's four letters long
stories with F and she had her two
middle fingers up as she is saying it
just very intense f this F that if you
if these people and lest you think that
I'm just pulling one little clip out of
context that actually the women's March
was some normal totally balanced thing
and there was just one kook out there
that that isn't the case here's a shot
from the women's march of hole scores of
people I don't maybe 100 or 150 people
out there dancing and yelling and
rapping and saying poetry about how
we're all a bunch of rapists you're
there okay well first of all I just like
to say no we're not that's not who we
are
but we'll examine why they react that
way why the March for Life reacts the
way they do what it tells us about the
left and the right first I got to thank
our friends over at ancestry there are
many paths to finding your family's
story whichever way you choose it is
easy to get started with ancestry I have
used ancestry since before the daily
wire even existed and then they came out
with ancestry DNA which is very cool you
know you spit in the to of you mail it
in ancestry DNA can reveal your ethnic
origins it can provide historical
details about your family and it brings
those family stories to life but it's
not like ancestry DNA just says okay
Michael you're from Italy like oh yeah
you don't say really you you can hone in
and it shows you which region of the
country you're from and it can kind of
show you how your family moved from
region to region all around the world
how they ended up in America you can
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
you can figure out how they moved all
over the place
no other DNA service offers this kind of
interactive experience it's very easy to
get started right now with answer
street DNA you can start exploring your
family's story today head over to
ancestry.com slash Knowles to get your
ancestry DNA kit and start your free
trial
that's ancestry.com slash Knowles you
are gonna love it I always love doing
this I find really weird stories about
my ancestors turns out one of them may
have possibly mocked a saint
as he was on the scaffold ready to be
hanged not not the brightest moment my
family history but interesting
nonetheless ancestry.com / Knowles check
it out
okay so you got the March for Life
vibrant happy normal joyful then you got
the women's March screaming vulgar
creepy weird full of a bunch of people
who don't seem to have everything
together exactly it shows us which way
the two parties are going obviously on
the question of life one of them is
life-affirming one of them is not
life-affirming
but more broadly one side the right is
approaching politics from a position of
gratitude we've talked about this before
the the March for Life is when you talk
to them they say I'm just so happy for
this life I have Jorge who says I grew
up and I had a really tough upbringing
in foster care and I'm still so happy
that I'm alive today thank you so much
to my mother for choosing life thank you
so much for supporting me it's true on
the national level people who say gosh I
love my country I love everything my
country has done for me what a wonderful
place what a wonderful time to be alive
thank you family I love my family I love
my tradition I love the cultural
inheritance that I have that's
increasingly what the right does how
about the left the left does not
approach politics primarily from a place
of gratitude it approaches politics
primarily from a place of entitlement so
you have these screaming people out
there saying give me gimme gimme I want
this I want that give me free healthcare
give me abortions whenever I want them
let me kill my child let me do this let
me do that it's my right me me me me and
we know for a fact that when you
approach life selflessly when you give
of yourself to others you will be more
gratified you will be more satisfied
with your life you will be more joyful
and when you live life primarily about
satisfying your own desire
and satisfying your own appetites you
are going to be miserable and if you
don't believe me just look at the two
faces the face of Jorge at the March for
Life and the face of that crazy British
ladies screaming fu and fu and the F
this and have that it's not just at the
marches that you can see it on the
presidential campaign trail the
entitlement mentality has made it all
the way to the top of the polls in Iowa
and in New Hampshire we are seven days
away from the Iowa caucuses the Iowa
caucuses are the first big moment in the
presidential primary campaign this is
the first time voters are going to go to
the polls and it's not just gonna be
these different surveys and answering
the phone and saying I like this
candidate more than that cabinet they're
actually gonna put their vote on the
line we are seven days away
Bernie Sanders is killing him he's
absolutely killing it according to every
poll there's a new New York Times Siena
College Bowl right now Bernie Sanders in
first place at 25% people to judge at
18% Joe Biden at 17
Liz Warren at 15 that means that Bernie
Sanders is outside the margin of error
right now it it couldn't just be
explained away as some weird statistical
fluke according to the New York Times
he's seven points up on his rivals and
the rest of the pack is basically all
within a point point or two of each
other another poll has Bernie up it's a
little bit closer but it's still up this
is CBS News and YouGov has Bernie
Sanders at 26 then Joe Biden at 25 then
Budaj age of 22 then Warren at 15 there
are other polls that are showing Bernie
doing very very well so as a result of
this the establishment is freaking out
because the establishment wants either
Joe Biden or assuming Joe Biden is now
going to work and there's a lot of
reason to think he won't work Elizabeth
Warren the Des Moines Register is still
trying to make Liz Warren happen but
they're not going to make Liz Warren
happen because nobody likes Liz Warren
which is why she's at the bottom of all
these polls the Des Moines Register
enjoys endorses Warren
so it'd be endorsement begins at this
moment when the very fabric of American
life is at stake Elizabeth Warren is the
president this nation
okay that's kind of normal boilerplate
endorsement stuff but then they go
further and they describe Elizabeth
Warren and the other candidates as
someone who would quote treat truth is
something that matters a woman whose
nickname is liya watha focus a woman who
is a lily white as the newly driven snow
pretended for decades to be a Native
American for professional gain a woman
who submitted a recipe of basically crab
and mayonnaise salad to a Native
American cookbook called powwow Chow I
kid you not
a woman who lied about sending her kids
to public school a woman who lied about
being fired as a teacher because she was
pregnant
a woman who probably lied about what she
had for breakfast this morning she is a
candidate who would quote treat truth as
something that matters the voters know
that that is total BS and a lot of what
you're seeing in terms of Bernie's rise
a lot of what you're seeing in terms of
the polarization of the two political
parties is because people know that the
mainstream media and the establishment
are just full of it they see through it
now in part that's because of how our
politics has evolved in part that's
because of how technologies evolved
we'll get into that in a second but this
is not an isolated case because guess
what the polls are showing Bernie's up
in New Hampshire - we'll get to all of
that but first I have got to thank our
friends over at ring I've been on the
road for a while I'm in Washington DC
I've been away from my apartment but
luckily I can feel safe because ring is
there to keep me safe
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere and you'd
know about them because I've told you
about them what ring does very simple
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world whether you're in
your bedroom whether you're at the
office whether you're in Washington DC
whether you're on a beach in Hawaii you
can stay connected so if you got a
package delivery guy you can see here
and speak to them if you got a burglar
trying to bust down your door you can
see here and speak to them and they're a
bunch of videos that have gone up and
they they're very funny because the
burgers get chased away the reason they
go up is they get uploaded to the cloud
so even if a burglar steals your ring
doorbell
you can feel rest rest assured that
you'll be able to see that video as a
listener you have a special offer right
now on a ring starter kit with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home use the
company that I trust for my own safety
go to ring.com slash anoles K no W l es
that is ring.com slash Knowles now one
thing that is not safe right now is the
future of the Democratic Party because
Bernie Sanders is surging to the lead
not just in Iowa also in New Hampshire
we have an NBC News Marist Poll right
now puts Bernie at 22% in New Hampshire
second place is Budaj edge at 17% then
Warren then Biden at 15 Warren again at
the bottom of the pack at 13 CNN
University of New Hampshire poll Bernie
all the way up at 25% Biden way down
it's 16% a nine-point gap between Bernie
and the second-place candidate then
Budaj edge at 15 and Warren again at the
bottom at 12 and then there's another
poll this this one is is pretty wild
it's the craziest of all WBUR of New
Hampshire Bernie up at 28% in New
Hampshire followed by Budaj edge at 16
followed by Biden at 13 and Warren at 12
so there's a 12-point gap there for
Bernie according to that that New
Hampshire poll what all of this means is
that bernie is a real threat what all of
this means is that Bernie might be the
Democrats Trump you get to what that
means in a second what all of this means
is that the Democratic Party is becoming
more honest you know for years and years
for a century the American Left defended
radical regimes the Soviet Union I think
of the reporters Lincoln Steffens and
Walter durante talked about how they saw
the future in the Soviet Union and it
worked but carried water for Joseph
Stalin you had the American Life
the honest voices of the American left
defending Fidel Castro defending Mao
Zedong defending all sorts of awful
radical socialist communist regimes but
there was this this kind of veneer of
moderation or respectability that is now
falling away it's falling away because
the establishment is losing its
credibility Bernie is the Democrats
Trump he is the answer to Trump how is
that they're very different people
obviously Donald Trump billionaire
businessman instinctively patriotic anti
politically correct and he's a big tough
guy Bernie Sanders none of those things
Bernie is a career politician it's the
only it's the only job he's ever had
it's the only it's the nearest thing to
a job he's ever had
he's a radical socialist a true believer
he's never accomplished anything other
than complaining for 50 years even even
as a legislator he's never really
accomplished a thing and yet they there
are some similarities between the two
guys first of all they're both absolute
middle fingers to the establishment
there they're also both cartoons of
their political parties when you think
of what's the difference between the
left and the right well the the right is
more patriotic right the right is more
grateful the right is more interested in
private property the right is more
willing to speak bluntly Trump is the
caricature of that he's the cartoon of
that I mean there was an early campaign
event in 2016 where Donald Trump
literally hugged to the American flag
it's smiling beaming ear to ear with
that right it's a it's the total extreme
of everything we think of when we think
of conservatives or of the right and
what is Bernie Bernie is he is a living
complaint right all heat I mean that's
why that's why Larry David plays him on
Saturday Night Live is because you have
this idea this kind of old guy who all
he does is always complains about
everything that's Bernie Sanders and
that is the American left when you think
about the American left you think about
people complaining and whining and
moaning because they don't get enough
free stuff and they want everything to
be for
and they don't nothing's good enough for
them in this country and they just feel
entitled to everybody else's money and
property and me me me me me right Bernie
Bernie Sanders said that he would he
would raise taxes on everybody making
more than twenty nine thousand dollars a
year which is virtually everybody he's
saying yeah I'm gonna take money from
pretty much everybody when I get into
office okay
those are the cartoons of the left and
the right and you see them in Trump and
Bernie you don't really see that in
Trump and Biden Biden isn't a cartoon of
the Democratic Party certainly not the
Democratic Party today and the other the
other thing that Trump and Bernie have
in common they're both authentic they're
all they're ton of reasons to criticize
Bernie maybe even some reasons to
criticize Trump but what you can't say
about them is that they're inauthentic I
mean with both of those guys what you
see is what you get even I remember two
Trump mention this when they asked him
if he was going to get a dog in the
White House because every president
needs to have a dog and it looks really
good for the photos and the magazines
want you to have a dog and they said you
gonna get a dog and he said now no I
don't really like dogs I feel like it
wouldn't work for me I feel like people
would see through that and they would
they would if he all of a sudden Trump
pretended to be this nice warm fuzzy guy
they would of course see through that
and he said I'm gonna be authentic I'm
not gonna pretend to voters that I'm
something that I'm not same thing with
Bernie Sanders you know he's pretty
pretty authentic guy pretty sincere as
far as politicians go and both of them
have a very personal connection to their
supporters I mean Trump you know won the
presidential campaign in 2016 on
grassroots supporters and a bunch of
cheap hats it's not like this guy was
the favorite of the big dollar donors
okay this guy had genuine grassroots
support same thing with Bernie Bernie is
all small dollar donations he's not he's
not a favorite of the donor class far
from it they're doing their best to
deprive him of the nomination just like
they did in 2016 the reason that that
authenticity in that personal touch
matters right now is because the media
have become much more personal they've
become much more authentic rather than
you think of the 1960 presidential
election and John F Kennedy and Richard
Nixon are going to do
eight the issues and they're both really
kind of stiff and on television it's in
grainy black and white that was as
personal as it got 50 60 years ago now
we're on tik-tok right now we're on
Instagram now we're on periscope and
everything is so personal you can see
the pores on somebody's face requires
you to be much more sincere much more
authentic I think that's why Elizabeth
Warren is at the bottom of the pack
right now is she is the by far the least
sincere candidate in the race I mean
she's lied about every major point of
her biography and and she's in order to
overcome that she would have to get real
and she's not capable of doing it now
Bernie has some big weaknesses Joe Biden
has some big advantages and there's
actually some secret gossip going around
among the Democratic senators which
senator Ted Cruz told me the other night
on our podcast verdict with Ted Cruz
that might shape the way we look at the
rest of this race we will get to that
we'll get to what that means for
impeachment we will get to the very sad
news about Kobe Bryant but first I've
got to thank our friends over at Express
VPN it is so important to use a VPN I
need to make you understand this okay I
know what you think you think what I
used to think which is nobody wants my
dad it doesn't really matter who cares
it's not a big deal when you weren't
going on the internet without a VPN you
are broadcasting everything that you
were doing on the Internet to the entire
world and listen if you listen to this
show you probably go on some pretty
pretty crazy websites so right on that
incognito window at Daily wire.com know
what I mean or you've got your financial
information out there or just you need a
VPN and there are a lot of VPN providers
out there you've probably heard of a few
of them but I only recommend the brands
that I believe in and I really believe
in Express VPN I can say with full
confidence expressvpn is my favorite on
the market because expressvpn doesn't
log your data a lot of really cheap VPNs
there are free VPNs the way that they do
it is they they log your data and they
sell your data that's not what
expressvpn does right now protect
yourself with a VPN that I use and trust
use my link expressvpn dot-com slash
Michael and I
tae-il today get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn dot-com / michael expressvpn
comm / michael to learn more bernie is a
real threat here but bernie has a big
weakness
Bernie's weakness is low support among
black voters Democrats cannot win the
race if they don't have 90% support
among black voters high 80s at least
they need to have a lock on the black
vote in order to win the general
election but Bernie does very poorly
among black voters that's the only
reason Joe Biden is still in the race
Joe Biden does very well among black
voters and so the only rhyming Joe Joe
Biden is such a bad candidate he has
everything going against him Joe Biden
is simply too old and he looks it on the
campaign trail
unlike Bernie who is very old but at
least he has energy Joe Biden is getting
confused all the time Joe Biden has
accomplished a very very little despite
being in public office for about 50
years I guess the same as Bernie Joe
Biden is it doesn't really seem to have
any core beliefs that one can mention
he's just a weak candidate and
especially in an era where Democrats
care so much about identity politics
he's an old white guy so that counts
against him too the reason Joe Biden is
still in the race is because he has
support among black voters but
Democratic elites who they're called the
super-delegates in the Democratic Party
these elites these super-delegates have
an outsized influence on who the nominee
is regardless of who the voters pick
they get to cast their own votes and in
some cases outweigh the will of the
primary voters the super-delegates may
be giving up on Biden I was speaking to
senator Ted Cruz the other night on her
show verdict with Ted Cruz and he said
the rumor going around the Senate is
that the super-delegates have soured on
Biden and that is wide during
impeachment which we'll get to in a
second the Democratic House impeachment
managers through Joe Biden under the bus
is because the party elites don't think
Biden has what it takes
trouble is Joe Biden is the only
relatively normal candidate who can beat
Bernie Sanders and they don't want
Bernie Sanders to win the nomination
either so
Berni right now in in this at this
moment with the current level of black
support that he adds he would be very
easy to beat in the general election
okay and that's I think the party act
the party elites and among the Democrats
are nervous about Bernie's radicalism
but they're also nervous that he's going
to lose a bunch of states however if
Bernie can connect with black voters and
he has been able to reach out beyond
just white voters so he's got decent
support among Hispanic voters but if he
can reach out to black voters he could
be a very dangerous candidate in a
general election because he does connect
with people in a way that Biden Budaj
edge and Warren simply do not and he
does have an authenticity to him and he
is a middle finger to the establishment
which everybody wants to send because
the parties are getting clearer the left
and the right are getting clearer and
more honest and they don't like that
mealy-mouthed double-talk from the
establishment speaking of impeachment
there is a pivotal moment going on right
now as we speak in the impeachment trial
the Democrats have finished their
impeachment arguments the Trump team is
now about to make their impeachment
arguments and then we're gonna see if
I'm gonna be stuck in DC covering
impeachment for the next six weeks or if
I'm gonna get to go home all of that
will rest on just a few people we'll get
to that in a second first I have got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube and
why don't specifically mention the
pro-life cause because well the
pro-abortion activists are shouting
their abortions on national TV and
calling preborn babies parasites
pro-lifers are fighting back all of us
here at the Daily wire have spoken out
for life you remember last year been
addressed a crowd of a hundred thousand
people at the March for Life in DC well
as a result of that or advertisers were
targeted by left-wing operatives and we
lost a lot of revenue and this is a
constant battle to protect pro-life
advocacy from the forces of abortion
live action has experienced the same
thing live action is one of the most
important voices in the pro-life
movement they've helped expose Planned
Parenthood and other abortion mills for
the horrific crimes that they commit
pro-abortion activists have targeted
live action they censor them on social
media when they don't succeed in kicking
them off altogether that's why our daily
wire.com members are so important
your membership helps keep our cameras
on and our microphones turned up
even when the left pressures our
sponsors you keep our pro-life message
from being canceled and from now until
January 31st a portion of any daily
wire.com membership will be donated to
live action with promo code live action
easy enough to remember daily wired.com
head on over there and make your
pro-life voice heard we'll be right back
with a lot more
all right we have got to get to
impeachment you see today is a pivotal
day you can hear more about this in
depth if you head on over to to verdict
with Ted Cruz which is the podcast we're
doing every night the senator comes over
from the Capitol and we immediately go
into what happened on the day and he
gives us a behind the scenes look into
impeachment and thank you to everybody
who's listened and subscribed and left a
five-star review because now that show
is the number one podcast on the charts
Joe Rogan endorses Bernie Sanders and
then a day or two later verdict with Ted
Cruz becomes the number one podcast I'm
just saying I'm that look maybe it's a
coincidence who knows maybe it's not
let's just very quickly an impeachment
cover what's happening today
the House Democrats have finished their
opening arguments the Trump team now
gets to make their argument they gave us
a preview of what that argument is going
to be just on Saturday two days ago here
is a quick clip that sums it up
everything that guy just says bull thank
you alright that's pretty much the
argument that the trust Trump lawyers
made Joe Pesci is not on the Trump legal
team but the Trump legal team did make
what I call the My Cousin Vinny argument
that House Democrats ran their mouths
Adam Schiff ran their mouths for three
days four days and then going into the
middle of the night and then the Trump
legal team gets up there and pretty much
said hey everything that guy just said
is BS the defense really starts in
earnest today and the defense actually
matters I think some people are looking
at impeachment and everyone's eyes are
glazing over and they say oh who cares
Trump is obviously gonna be acquitted
he's not gonna be removed from office
let's just move on we'll think about
something else the Trump legal teams
defense matters not because Trump could
be removed from office I think that is
virtually impossible it would require 20
Republican senators to suddenly flip on
the president flip on their voters Trump
Curley has a 95 percent approval rating
among Republicans it's just not going to
happen
however Republican
have fifty three seats in the Senate
Democrats and Democratic leaning
independents have 47 seats 53 to 47 the
real vote is not about the vote to
remove Trump from office you're not
going to lose 20 Republican senators the
real worry is about the vote to call
witnesses that's what's really being
debated right now because if they don't
call any more witnesses in this
impeachment trial then this whole thing
could be over on Saturday and I can go
home to LA if they do vote to call more
witnesses like the house didn't get
enough witnesses when they voted to
impeachment so now all of a sudden we
need more witnesses if they vote to do
that this thing could drag on for weeks
all you need for that to happen is for
squishy Republicans 53 to 47 so you lose
for Republicans all of a sudden they're
gonna call all these witnesses it's
going to go on forever my ability to
return home to Los Angeles relies on
Mitt Romney not being a huge jerk which
means I need to start shopping for
apartments in Washington pretty soon I
think there are other Republicans too
who are kind of squishy on this
obviously there is Susan Collins in
Maine there's Lisa Murkowski in Alaska
there's several others so the Trump team
really does need to make a good case the
good thing is that the facts are on
their side the facts favor the Trump
team the question is are they gonna play
it safe or are they gonna go for the
jugular gets to what we were talking
about earlier the party is becoming more
honest the party is becoming more clear
the Trump legal team should be very
clear here the Democrats have been clear
the Democrats have been clear since 2017
they have said since Trump got elected
that they are going to impeach this guy
they don't know what for but they'll
figure it out right they tried to
impeach him for Russia then they tried
to impeach him for his taxes
then they tried to impeach him for
stormy Daniels then they tried to
impeach him for Ukraine it's it's always
been an impeachment in search of a crime
Representative Al Green the Democrats
said it in 2017 he said I'm afraid if we
don't impeach this president he might
get reelected Adam Schiff reiterated
this just the other day during the
impeachment trial he said we cannot
allow this impeachment to be decided at
the ballot box we got to handle it
beforehand what the obvious reason is
because Adam Schiff thinks that the
voters are gonna reelect Donald Trump so
are you gonna play it safe you're gonna
go for the jugular you're gonna be clear
here or not the Trump team on the one
hand could play it safe and say hey the
things you're claiming we did we didn't
really do and we'll go through it point
by point and show why we didn't do that
thing okay that would be the safe
version the aggressive version the clear
version would be to say like Joe Pesci
everything that guy just said is BS but
more to it
the president has the right to
investigate corruption there's no it's
not a quid pro quo it's not an
impeachable offense the president was
investigating corruption who's
corruption Joe Biden's corruption they
need to they need to stop playing
defense and start playing offense on the
Trump legal team they need to say look
this whole thing you're accusing us of
doing it's a bunch of BS but what about
what you did what about what Joe Biden
and his son Hunter did what about
Purisima what about this crooked deal
that the Obama administration set up
that they basically admitted to in
official email threads about Joe and
hunter Biden naming them specifically
what about that put it all on Ukraine
and what you will see happen is first of
all it would be a much more convincing
argument but second of all it's going to
affect the election in a way that's very
helpful to the president impeachment
generally has helped President Trump and
it has hurt the Democrats however if all
you're talking about is a allegations of
Trump's corruption that doesn't look
great put it back on the Democrats use
this opportunity of impeachment as a way
to really hammer home the utter
corruption not just of this impeachment
trial but of the Obama administration
actions through Joe Biden in Ukraine
that led to the impeachment in the first
place bring it up go for the jugular I
hope they do it we'll see it because
it's going to start in just a couple
hours now another big story on
impeachment today that the mainstream
media is making a big deal out of but
actually does not matter at all is a
leak from John Bolton's new book and
you're going to see this is
to be the top trend on Twitter all day
John Bolton is the former national
security adviser to Donald Trump there's
a leak out now from his new memoir
that's coming out that was sent to the
New York Times and it says that in his
book john bolton accuses President Trump
of personally telling him that 391
million dollars in aid to Ukraine should
be frozen until Ukrainian officials
announced the investigation into the
possible corruption from the Obama
administration from Joe Biden from
hunter Biden that's the allegation
bombshell now john bolton has come out
and said this was an unprofessional
irresponsible leak i didn't leak this
clearly someone in the review process
leaked this and the Trump team has come
out pretty strongly against john bolton
here and and president Trump has denied
speaking to john bolton about it
none of that matters because the story
is BS from the very beginning let's say
that Trump did exactly what joe john
bolton allegedly accuses him of doing
the president has every right to do it
the president has every right to
investigate corruption the president has
every right to use his negotiating
leverage to force a partner overseas to
live up to their obligations every
president has done this every president
should be able to do this this is basic
and fundamental to foreign policy the
way to really take the wind out of the
Democrats sails is to say hold on even
if what you're saying is true Trump was
perfectly right to do it what's the
problem what's the crime you're saying
the president can't investigate
corruption what the what the left is
relied on through all of the impeachment
forces what they have relied on is the
insinuation of doing something wrong
sources tell me that Trump did something
really bad with Russia we can't we don't
know exactly what he did that was bad
but it was really bad yeah it might not
have been a crime but anyway it was
really bad and so we got to get rid of
then it turns out it didn't do anything
with Russia and we don't need to get rid
of him and the things they were alleging
that he did aren't even illegal well we
think that Trump might have done
something bad on his taxes so we got to
get rid of him
well we think what he did in Ukraine
might have been really terrible and
illegal you got a zero in on the details
here what did he do if he did it would
that be illegal and the answer is no
it's just all smoke there's there's it's
all insinuations all sizzle no steak
how many more metaphors can I use it's
it's just nothing but the only people
who are gonna focus on this john bolton
thing or the mainstream media and house
democrats desperate to find something to
impeach the guy for i think that story
goes absolutely nowhere now before we go
i want to get to kobe bryant very sad
story kobe bryant you know what one of
the greatest athletes of his age one of
the greatest basketball players ever
personally a very interesting guy he
spoke fluent Italian he grew up in part
in in Italy because he came from a
basketball family and his father was
playing over there he was Catholic he
would be went to a Catholic parish right
right near where I go to church actually
very interesting guy he was an Academy
Award winner
how many basketball players become
Academy Award winners you know I don't
follow basketball so I really can't
comment on Kobe Bryant's basketball
playing at all but I did see Kobe Bryant
perform one time and I saw him perform
as a surprise performance at the
Hollywood Bowl when John Williams the
composer of Star Wars and Indiana Jones
he was playing a concert and in the
middle of the show out walks kobe bryant
to debut this poem that he wrote called
dear basketball and there was a short
film with it and john williams had
composed the music and so there's kobe
bryant you know one of the greatest
athletes of his age standing there
reciting this poem at the hollywood bowl
with john williams one of the greatest
composers of his age playing behind him
and it was a really cool experience and
i can't say that i saw Kobe perform at
what he's known for performing
did I did get to see him perform and
then the guy struck down in his youth 41
years old and his daughter who I think
was 13 years old so sad
really tragic what do we take away from
this what can we do about this obviously
we can pray for Kobe and for his
daughter and for his family and
everybody affected by this for all the
unnamed people who were on that
helicopter who are not making the
headlines but who also have families who
also have lives we can pray for them
what do we take away in terms of our own
lives first part of it and I think this
is some of what's so shocking to us
about about Kobe's death is that tragedy
happens to everyone
Kobe Bryant is a guy who has it all he's
a guy who would commute to work in a
helicopter right Kobe's a rich famous
incredible athlete
handsome Academy Award winner great
family apparently a thriving spiritual
life right just everything right cut
down it reminds us that tragedy happens
to everybody everybody doesn't matter
how rich you are doesn't matter how
wonderful and thriving and flourishing
your life is happens to everybody that
scares us the other reason that we're
reacting in this I think in this
shocking way even beyond Kobe's
importance to the culture is because it
reminds us that you do not know when
your time will come what a fluke this
guy is about to start the next chapter
of his life and the helicopter just goes
down Oh lights go off like that and that
scares us it reminds us that we will all
die and we will all die sooner than we
think we go about our lives day to day
feeling as though we're never going to
die but we will it will happen sooner
than we think it's a reminder that life
is a preparation for death it makes us
think about what happens after death
what it all means where the significance
of our
life is today are you ready to die if it
happened to you today would you be ready
that is a startling question and it
brings us back to the March for Life the
difference through the March for Life
and the women's March that happened the
week before would you be ready you know
you on the one hand you have these
people at the march for life joyful
exuberant
vibrant vital if the last thing that you
saw of their lives were those frames
from the March for Life you would say
man they lived a good life they really
did it they really figured it out if the
last frames of your life were you
wearing some stupid pink hat screaming
curse words and saying F this and F that
and F you and you would say gosh that
person they messed up somewhere
they just didn't they just didn't figure
it out did they hmm I was a troubled
person they didn't quite get to it and
it's a reminder to that life is so
precious I mean we are none of us have
met Kobe Bryant statistically zero
people listening to this podcast right
now including me have ever met Kobe
Bryant and yet we're all really really
sad about his death and we're especially
sad about the death of his daughter
because it's a reminder that life is
precious it's a reminder that the March
for Life errs are correct and the people
who are marching against life and
shrieking to end lives before they've
barely begun are wrong we know we just
know in our gut that life is precious
that it matters that even if there's
suffering in there there is meaning to
life and that it is a good thing
and we can all pray on that we can pray
for Kobe and his daughter and we can
pray for ourselves that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt I'll be back tomorrow in the
meantime you can catch me on verdict
with Ted Cruz tonight see you there
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation